there's a video going around Nordstrom
ransacked for a hundred thousand dollars
of the merchandise they're not even
covering their faces anymore I saw a
video of guys robbing a supermarket
they didn't even wear a mask
just it's three dudes they walk in they
grab it they felt their car walk out go
to the car and start filling up while
the guy films them there's a video of a
woman stealing from a store she just
throws it in her car jumps in her car
speeds off
this is what people don't get Civil War
or I should say Revolution or social
breakdown in many countries especially
the ones that I've seen
it is not like a bunch of people go
outside stand in front of a Podium and
say we the people of the Continental
Liberty faction hereby Proclaim it's
like a group of people run through a
building smashing up things and setting
fires for no reason and then in the
chaos people start to seize power power
shifts you get a bunch of people looting
and smashing and then when this spreads
too far and it spreads to political
areas the system breaks down